c'est donc fait jacques chirac avait
annoncé qu'il aurait l'occasion
d'exprimer ses choix personnels
eh bien il l'a fait aujourd'hui en
important ce matin son soutien et son
vote au candidat de l'ump nicolas
sarkozy le président de la république
qui a également accepté le départ du
ministre de l'intérieur du gouvernement
départ qui sera effectif lundi prochain
une déclaration du chef de l'état courte
mais claire alix bouilhaguet francis
forget et son dernier conseil des
ministres
mais à la sortie nicolas sarkozy ne dira
pas un mot
la séquence a été soigneusement calais
il y a deux jours avec le chef de l'état
lors de leur tête à tête hebdomadaire à
midi celle épilogue d'un faux suspense
de l'elysée mais sans décorum jacques
chirac annonce lui-même le départ de son
ministre du gouvernement pour ne
froisser personne
la décision était prise en présence de
dominique de villepin
cet entretien a été pour nous pour le
premier ministre est pour moi l'occasion
de saluer sont là-bas et son engagement
ses résultats au ministère de
l'intérieur pour justifier son soutien
nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac s'appuie
sur le choix de l'ump
cette formation politique a choisi de
soutenir la candidature de nicolas
sarkozy à l'élection présidentielle
et ceci en raison de ses qualités
c'est donc tout naturellement que je lui
apporterai mon vote
et mon soutien un soutien sabre est
mesurée du chef de l'état comme on est
con deux heures plus tard la réaction de
nicolas sarkozy sobre également
ce qui change très importante du
président de la république a vu dieu qui
m'a touché à la fois sur le plan
personnel et son clan politique a une
grande signification
à partir de lundi prochain nicolas
sarkozy sera donc un candidat à plein
temps son successeur place beauvau
pourrait être françois baroin l'actuel
ministre de l'outre-mer mais
contrairement à nicolas sarkozy il ne
sera ni ministre d'état numéro deux du
gouvernement